hello everyone my videos for the past
week were mostly about like the London
chest classic and alpha zero versus
stockfish so it would be nice to get
back into the classics at least for a
bit and for this occasion I chose this
was a suggestion from a subscriber I
chose the game Carlos story Repetto
versus a world champion Emanuel Lasker
and this game it's I mean it's a
brilliant game but it's also it also has
a lot of historical significance now
something about Carlos Saura Repetto
he's a grandmaster from Mexico and this
game is actually called some call it the
Seventh Seal but people from Mexico
mostly call it the Mexican immortal and
when I heard this you know Mexican
immortal like I immediately wanted to
see this game I don't think I've ever
seen it I know I know of Torre and of
course everyone knows who am i Lasker is
but I don't think I've ever I ever saw
this particular game it was played in
1925 in a very strong tournament in
Moscow you know I mean what do you
expect it's a chess tournament in Moscow
of course it's gonna be strong there
were 21 players playing there and by
strong I mean Akiba Rubinstein one 12th
place in the end so imagine that Akiba
Rubenstein who was at one point
considered to be the strongest player in
the world got twelfth place Efimova
liubov had a brilliant tournament he won
first place with 15 and a half points
followed by Emmanuel Lasker with 14
points and in third place was josé raúl
capablanca so you know very strong
players two world champions in the first
three places fourth was Frank Marshall
and in fifth place was Carlos Torres
Repetto so definitely a strong
Grandmaster and you know winning a fifth
place in such a tournament is is you
know great stuff so let's see this game
we have d4 Tory has the white pieces and
Knight to f6 and Knight to f3 we have E
six and Bishop to g5 and now many of you
play Bishop to g5 knowing it's the Toray
attack and it's the Tauri attack because
of carlos toro Repetto and because of
this game played against world champion
Emanuel Alaska in the mosque of
tournament of 1925
but you'll see what I mean by this c5 by
Oscar we have III seek after Sun b4e
captors and e4 and Bishop to e7 Knight B
to D to bite or a d6 c3 Knight B to d7
and Bishop to d3 b6 biological preparing
to develop the lights were Bishop and
Knight to c4 Bishop to b7 now Queen e2
Queen to c7 Tory castles Lasker castles
and rook F 2 e1 now developing rooks
rook F de 8 called Alaska also does this
rook a to D 1 and we have night to f8 so
all of the whites pieces are perfectly
developed and now it's time to find a
plan Tory plays Bishop back to c1 and
whenever I see a bishop retreat in a
game I know it's gonna be a great game
something like whenever I see a nice
rook lift Knight to d5 by Lasker and we
have Knight to g5 now with some pressure
on the h7 pawn but nothing too serious
b5 kicking the knight Knight to a 3 B 4
seek after some before night capture
some before now Alaska is threatening to
capture this strong light square bishop
and the move you would expect is
probably something like Bishop could be
1 and maybe move like age 6 or rope to
c8 depends but instead of this after
night two before Tory plays Queen to h5
now threatening to capture on h7 as the
Queen night and Bishop are attacking it
so Bishop captures on g5 g 6 was
probably a better move but Alaska
doesn't see anything wrong with Bishop
captures on g5 Bishop captures on g5
Bishop captures on g5 and now Knight
captures on d3 a rook lift with a temple
rook after Sunday 3 and we have Queen to
a5 a very strong move Alaska
immobilizing this dark square Bishop
also threatening ideas like f6 to win
the piece and here we have B for trying
to kick the Queen away from from pinning
this Bishop Queen to a5 by Alaska and
now rocked Ajit
positioning the rook for some future
Bishop f6 h6 ideas we have h6 here and
now comes Knight to c4 the piece is lost
there's there's nothing to do here but
Tory takes this opportunity to bring his
long-lost knight on a three back into
the game and here lasker plate Queen to
d5 and it seems odd that he doesn't
capture the bishop but what would happen
if the bishop is captured is probably
something like H captors and g5 Knight
captures on d6 now attacking the Queen
and also the bishop on b7 and after
Queen g6 Queen captures Knight captures
and maybe knife capture some b7
attacking the knight tonight goes back
rock characters and after Knight to b3
the material is equal and it's probably
something like the draw but I don't know
I mean Alaska was the stronger player
it's it's very a new rule that he
decided not to go for this but maybe
maybe that's just the case he considers
himself the stronger player he didn't
want to allow Tori probably any drawing
chances so after Knight to c4 he played
the Queen to d5 and here we have knife
to e3 attacking the Queen and again here
Lasker plays Queen to b5 and it's
interesting why doesn't Alaska captured
the d4 pawn well of course he still
wants to pin this bishop here but if you
play Queen captures on b4 then you get
Bishop captures on h6 with threats of
rook captures on g7 and after Knight to
g6 Bishop to g5 Queen capture some b4
rook to d1 Bishop to e4 and Knight to g4
Queen to a4 probably Knight to f6 check
and after this something like this
position could arise you can't really
stop checkmate on g7 and this this
happens in all the variation this is
just one of them so black would probably
have to give up the Queen to stop this
but this is completely winning for white
so instead of capturing and before
Lasker plays Queen to b5 and now Bishop
capture
and h6 doesn't work simply you capture
the Queen Bishop captures and you don't
really threaten any discovery simply 96
covering up and white is lost here but
here comes the problem after Queen to b5
Lasker missed Tory's next move and the
next move is actually Bishop to f6 and
this is beautiful
by playing Bishop to have 6-year
threatening to capture on g7 also you
opened up attack on the black Queen and
b5 but also you're offering your own
Queen on h5 so what do you do here well
there's really nothing to do but accept
the Queen
any other move loses terribly so Lasker
captures it and here it comes
Lasker against the windmills rook
captures and g7 would check came to h8
this is the only move rook captures on
f7 check King to g8 again only move
again rook the g7 check King to h8 only
move now rod captures on b7 again a
discovered check from the bishop King
has to go back to g8 only move now
rocked g7 check again King has to go
back to h6 HH and now Rock to g5 check
again checking the king and now
attacking the Queen with the rook King
has to go to h7 now rook captures on
aged 5 and this was the position Carlos
story had to see before he went into all
of this this King to g6 move that the
bishop and rook will be attacked but he
saw everything and everything is
perfectly fine rook to h3 came to f6
captures on h6 and now you're simply
three pawns up in an endgame even world
champion Emanuel Lasker is unable to
stop this King g5 rope to h3 now raakhi
to b8 Rock to g3 check King to f6 rook
to f3 check King g6 and now a3 a5 a
capture B captures an f5 rook captures
Knight to c4 with a tempo also defending
the a3 pawn rook to d5 rocked a for
defending the d4 pawn Knight to d7
the e6 now with check kink has to go to
g5 and after g3 in in this position
Emanuel Lasker resigned the game it's
simply too much too much to take
I mean Europe for pawns moves like H
were coming
Lasker is getting smothered here so he
doesn't want to play this anymore and he
resigns the game and so Carlos story
like I said won't shift place in this
amazingly strong tournament last year
got second place in the end but still
this Mexican immortal game was created
and I don't think I mean on chess
games.com this game is called the
Seventh Seal although I don't think it
has anything to do with the movie
Seventh Seal there is a chess game in
that movie but I believe the pieces on
the board are just scrambled even at one
point they just like change scenes and
then the pieces look totally different
so I don't think they you know paid any
attention maybe this was a kind of a
template for that game but it wasn't
ever finished in the movie so yeah
that's the game and one year after this
game was played in 1926 carlos toro
Repetto
had a mental breakdown and he spent the
rest of his years in a mental
institution
which was kind of sad some people said
that it's due to his wife leaving him
for another man but you know that's what
happens if you spend your days playing
chess eventually you get to beat
Emmanuel Lasker and create the Mexican
immortal game but then again your wife
will leave you for another man I
probably want to play soccer or
something so yeah but a Ruben fine
visited Torre you know some years later
while he was in the mental institution
and Ruben fine said that he still could
play with chess so yeah that's the game
I do hope you enjoyed it thank you for
recommending such a lovely game where
Carl storie Repetto
defeats the world champion Emanuel
Lasker and now you know after this
Bishop to g5 move that is the torah'
attack why it's called the Torre attack
and it's because Carlos Toro rapido
rapido defeated world champion in Alaska
in the various
tournament in Moscow of 1925 so you know
do do share with your friends so yeah as
usual you can check two of my previous
videos here thank y'all for watching and
I will see you soon